non chez moi ça me convient de faire mon
stage dans une entreprise c'est pour
aimer mes yeux d'un kilomètre dans un
service un paréo toutefois ou ici c'est
pas les vacances à la carte
c'est dans une compagnie d'assurances
ici c'est notre salle de rangement et il
faudrait
bah complètement la restructurer c'est
quand même passé toute la séance dans un
cagibi tu trouves ça normal non on remet
comme hiver si tu trouvais que c'était
plus pratique et ça va là tranquille où
don mello par terre et à venir dans le
monde du travail
ça fait un an que j'attends comprenez ça
un nom mais dans votre boîte à la rue
après deux jours excusez moi je peux
vous aider je vous ai entendu je
travaille au service assurance
emprunteur 3 tu veux pouvoir faire
quelque chose je sais pas capituler le
dossier oui ces mots comment ça c'est
mort elle va être expulsé pourquoi t'as
pas pris le papier
et comment tu veux vérifier son dossier
si tu prends pas le tapis
en fait c'est quoi vos objectifs bah
c'est gagner plus d'argent
arrête de vouloir te la jouer là genre
je fais partie de la cour des grands ton
stage c'est un stage d'observation c'est
trop naïf de penser que c'est facile de
faire lumière brille mais c'est encore
plus facile de rien faire
tama malterre et ados étaient tous pour
toi
j'adore tout ce que tu dois faire cela
salir de l'accusé de choses affreuses
tapis la reloger la famille seul un
parti way quelques petits trucs à régler
encore comme c'était plein
ce stage a donc été une expérience très
enrichissante qui m'a permis de
découvrir un nouvel univers
j'ai rencontré des gens très
sympathiques qui m'ont appris beaucoup
de choses que je ne connaissais pas
pour le titre je pensais mettre l'enfant
du placard mais c'est peut-être pas non
plus 13 ans et port louis
non parce que je suis pris un enfant
voilà